le hemos estado poniendo un montón de
atención a la estructura molecular del
adn nuevamente tenemos un diagrama de
ella
aquí tenemos estas dos hebras de adn
formando una doble hélice y podemos ver
los signos que indican que en efecto
esto es parte de una molécula de adn en
particular podemos ver este anillo de 5
carbonos y de hecho pues vamos a
enumerar estos carbonos este es el
carbono 1 prime 2 prime 3 primer 4
primer y 5 prima y podemos ver aquí en
el carbono 2 primero que no está
enlazado con un oxígeno porque no
tenemos un grupo hidroxilo por aquí y
por eso sabemos que ésta no es una
ribosa es una de sox y ribosa aunque
esta de aquí también es una
desoxirribonucleico de
sox y ribonucleico esta parte de aquí
esta parte de la cadena se deriva de una
desoxirribonucleico esta parte proviene
de una de sox y ribosa ahora
preguntémonos qué es lo que tendríamos
que cambiar por aquí si en lugar de ver
a esto como una doble hélice de adn
quisiéramos verlo como si esta parte
fuera un arn mensajero que se está
generando a partir de la transcripción
de una sola hebra de adn aquí en la
derecha
bueno pues podemos empezar por aquí
porque para que esto sea una molécula de
arn tenemos que hacer algunos cambios
aquí en el carbono 2 prima porque
queremos convertir a ésta
desoxirribonucleico y drop silo en el
carbono 2 primer y tengo que hacer lo
mismo
todos los azúcares de la hebra de la
izquierda ok si queremos que esto sea
una hebra de rn así es que por aquí
también tenemos que agregar un grupo
hidroxilo y al hacer esto al cambiar al
grupo hidroxilo por el hidrógeno que
teníamos antes por aquí implícitamente
esto de aquí nos dice que ya no tenemos
una desoxirribonucleico se lo cual es un
indicador de que por lo menos tenemos
una columna vertebral de rn mientras que
por acá seguimos teniendo una columna
vertebral de un adn ok de un ácido
desoxirribonucleico ahora aquí podríamos
pensar que ya terminamos pero todavía no
porque las bases nitrogenadas en las
moléculas de arn son ligeramente
diferentes que en las moléculas de adn
en las moléculas de adn las bases
nitrogenadas son adenina y guanina estas
dos bases nitrogenadas son las que
tienen dos anillos esta de aquí es
adenina y esta de acá es guanina y luego
también tenemos las bases cito cine y un
estilo no no no espérame me estoy
adelantando citocina y timina y esta
base de aquí éxito cine y la de acá es
timina las dos son bases nitrogenadas
con un solo anillo y a las bases
nitrogenadas de un solo anillo como la
situación ahí la timina les llamamos
bases pyramid íneas mientras que a la
adenina y guanina que son bases
nitrogenadas con dos anillos les
llamamos purinas pero bueno todo esto es
simplemente un repaso por otro lado en
el a
n seguimos teniendo adenina seguimos
teniendo warning seguimos teniendo
oxitocina pero en la rn en lugar de
tener timina tenemos una molécula que es
realmente muy parecida llamada curas y
lo la forma en la que tenemos dibujada a
esta cosa y recuerda que empezamos con
dos hebras de adn
esta base nitrogenada que tenemos por
aquí es timina que hace puentes de
hidrógeno con adenina ahora si quisiera
yo tener una hebra de rn no puedo tener
timina necesito tener un asilo pero si
yo llegara y quitar a este grupo metilo
de aquí y lo sustituyera con un
hidrógeno aquí implícitamente entonces
tenemos aquí una base nitrogenada brasil
o ahora tenemos un asilo un asilo así es
que como puedes observar la timina y el
ura si lo son realmente muy parecidos
son bases nitrogenadas muy parecidas y
es por eso que pueden jugar un papel
similar todas las cosas con las que hace
puentes de hidrógeno la timina el uras y
lo también los hace el ura estilo hace
puentes de hidrógeno con la adenina al
igual que la timina que también hace
puentes de hidrógeno con la adenina y
todo lo demás por supuesto sigue siendo
exactamente igual ahora una pregunta
interesante puede ser oye porque un
asilo y no timina o también podríamos
preguntarnos oye por qué timina en lugar
de un asilo y de acuerdo a lo que he
estado leyendo el ur así lo es un poco
más propenso a generar errores puede ser
que ese enlace con algunas otras cosas
cuando se está leyendo el código así es
que es un poco más inestable que la
timina de hecho el uras y lo hace que la
rn y bueno toda la maquinaria de
transferencia de información el duras y
lo los hace menos estables
el brest y lo hace que el a rn
una forma menos estable de transferir
información y según lo que he leído en
la historia de la evolución casi todos
creen que el rn precedió al adn en las
primeras etapas de la vida había mucho
cambio todo el tiempo por lo cual las
bases duras y lo estaban muy bien había
muchos errores y muchos cambios y muchas
cosas por el estilo pero más adelante
cuando empezamos a necesitar una forma
más estable de preservar la información
sin tantos errores bueno ahí fue cuando
la timina llegó y ayudó a estabilizar la
situación
ok llegó la timina y ayudó a estabilizar
las cosas ahora también nos podemos
preguntar oye pero y el brazil o porque
sigue por ahí bueno pues el rn tiene un
montón de funciones por ahí andan
muchísimas moléculas de arn mensajero
tomando información del adn y llevándola
a que sea transcrita o traducida por los
ribosomas pero pues no queremos que los
arnés se queden por ahí para 100
de hecho nos conviene que sean
inestables así es que es un tema muy
interesante eso de por qué tenemos un
asilo en lugar de timina o el por qué
tenemos timina en lugar de un asilo pero
bueno estos dos son los indicadores de
que aquí de este lado izquierdo tenemos
una molécula de rn ahora si podemos
considerar a esta hebra de la izquierda
como una molécula de rn esta hebra de la
izquierda es a rn y si estamos
suponiendo que esto está sucediendo en
la transcripción cuando una parte de una
hebra de adn quiere replicar su
información entonces esto de aquí es a
rn mensajero y ahora qué es lo que está
pasando por aquí bueno vamos a pensar en
eso de la forma en la que está orientado
este a rn mensajero por aquí lo que
tenemos es un grupo fosfato cinco
primero cuatro primates primer grupo
fosfato
3 prima grupo fosfato así es que esto
está orientado de arriba a abajo de 5
1er
es prima mientras que la hebra de adn
está orientada en el sentido opuesto ok
este es un carbono 5 primer y este es un
carbono 3 prima por lo que tenemos
fosfato 3 primeras 5 prima fosfato así
es que tenemos el 3 prima arriba y abajo
tenemos el 5 prima ahora si quisiéramos
describir qué es lo que está pasando
utilizando nuestras bases nitrogenadas
podríamos decir oye tenemos por aquí a
nuestro rn mensajero
este es el extremo 5 prima y por aquí
está el extremo 3 prima y la base
nitrogenada de aquí arriba es un asilo
aunque hay tenemos por aquí al un asilo
y la segunda base nitrogenada por aquí
es la citosina ok la segunda base
nitrogenada es la citosina y esto está
siendo transcrito a partir de este
pedazo de adn
ok tenemos por aquí
y este adn este adn tiene una
orientación anti paralela es paralela
pero está como que volteado los azúcares
están apuntando en direcciones opuestas
así es que este es el extremo 3 prime y
este el extremo 5 prima y podemos ver
que el ura si lo está enlazado a través
de estos puentes de hidrógeno con una
adenina con esta adenina de aquí a denim
y vamos a poner estos dos guiones para
denotar el puente de hidrógeno y la
citosina la citosina está enlazada con
una guanina esta de aquí es una guanina
que tiene unos puentes de hidrógeno con
la citosina aunque ahí tenemos varios
puentes de hidrógeno en la izquierda
tenemos un a
en mensajero y en la derecha tenemos un
a de n y esto podría estar sucediendo
durante la transcripción ahora cuáles
tipos de arnaiz bueno pues ya hemos
hablado de esto en otros vídeos pero
pues tenemos el arn mensajero que tiene
una tarea muy importante y toma la
información del adn la saca del núcleo y
con la ayuda de los ribosomas y los rn
te hacen que esa información se traduzca
y bueno acabo de mencionar a otro tipo
de adn aunque ya acabamos de mencionar
al rnp que es la abreviación del rn de
transferencia así es que tenemos el
arnés de transferencia
en ti y en el vídeo de introducción a la
transcripción y traducción explicamos
cómo le hace el rn de transferencia para
hacer eso pero básicamente lo que sucede
es que el cnt tiene aminoácidos de un
lado y anti cordones del otro lado
y esos anti cordones básicamente se
emparejan con algunos jóvenes del arn
mensajero y de esa forma se pueden
construir las proteínas por aquí tenemos
un modelo de una molécula de la r n
y bueno muchas veces cuando estamos
pensando en el adn y en el rn pensamos
que él a rn y él a fnm son simplemente
intermediarios para poder transcribir la
información y eventualmente traducir esa
información en proteínas y muchas veces
eso es lo que sucede pero también hay
otras veces en las que simplemente
queremos el rn el a rn también juega un
papel muy importante en las células
además de ser la forma a partir de la
cual se transfiere la información y un
ejemplo es aquí el cnt que tiene una
configuración muy interesante porque en
esta molécula hay un tipo especial de
aminoácido que puede llegar y enlazarse
aquí y además los a
del otro lado tienen un anti codón y
bueno diferentes moléculas
efe nt tendrán distintos anti cordones y
distintos aminoácidos en las
por aquí así es que este es otro de los
usos del rn y luego también está el rn
ribosomal a r n ribosomal los cuales
tienen un papel muy importante en la
estructura de los ribosomas que es donde
sucede la traducción y bueno también
tenemos el micro y rn micro a rn que
puede ser usado para regular la
traducción de algún otro rn así es que
el adn tiene mucha fama y reciben toda
la atención pero el rn también es muy
pero muy muy muy muy importante y muchas
personas creen que el rn llegó primero y
que de hecho es muy probable que la
primera forma de vida eran simples
cadenas de rn que se estaban replicando
muchísimo y que el adn evolucionó a
partir del a rn eventualmente
no desapareció el fn porque es muy útil